before I actually show you the mechanics
of what the curl of a vector field
really is let's try to get a little bit
of intuition so here I've drawn I'm
going to just draw a 2-dimensional
vector field you can extrapolate the
three but when we're getting the
intuition it's good to do it in two and
so let's see when I don't even even
label the X and y-axis but this is X
this is y so when y is relatively low
our magnitude of vector goes in the x
direction when it increases a little bit
it gets a little bit longer so as we can
see as our change in the Y direction as
we go in the Y direction the X component
of our vectors get larger and larger and
maybe in the X direction they're there
they're constant regardless of your
level of X the magnitude change it stays
so forgiven forgiven why the the
magnitude of that of your X component
vector might stay the same so I mean
this vector field might look something
like this I'm just making up numbers
maybe it's just I don't know Y squared I
so the magnitude in the X Direction is
just a function of your Y value and as
your Y values get bigger and bigger the
magnitude in your X direction will get
bigger and bigger proportional to the
square the magnitude of the Y direction
but for any given X it's always going to
be the same it's only depend on Y so
here if even if we make X larger we
still get the same magnitude we still
get the same magnitude and remember
these are just sample points on our
vector field okay that's enough of just
getting the intuition behind that vector
field but let me ask you a question if I
were to let's say that this vector field
shows the velocity of a fluid at various
points and so you can view this you know
we're looking down on a river maybe if I
were to take a little twig or something
and I were to place it on in this fluid
so let me place the twig right here let
me draw my twig so let's say I place a
twig to funny-looking twig but that's
good enough let's say I place the twig
right there what's going to happen to
the twig well at this point on the twig
though the water is moving to the
right so it'll push this part of the
twig to the right at the top of the twig
the water is also moving to the right
maybe with a faster velocity but it's
also going to push the top of the twig
to the right but the top of the twig is
going to be being pushed to the right
faster than the bottom of the twig right
so what's going to happen the twig is
going to rotate right after I don't know
some period of time the twigs are going
to look something like this the bottom
will move a little bit to the right but
the top will move a lot more to the
right right and the whole thing would
have been shifted to the right but is
going to rotate a little bit and maybe
after a little bit further maybe it
looks something like this so you can see
that because the the the vector is
increasing in a direction that is
perpendicular to our direction of motion
right are we this is you know this
fairly simple example all of the vectors
point in the X direction but the
magnitude of the vectors increase they
increase perpendicular they increase in
the Y dimension right and when this
happens when you have the flow going in
the same direction but is going at a
different magnitude you see that any
object in it will rotate right so let's
think about that so if the derivative
the partial derivative of this vector
field with respect to Y is increasing or
decreasing if it's just changing that
means as we increase in Y or as we
decrease in Y the magnitude of the X
component of our vectors right the X
direction of our vectors changes and so
if you have a different speed for
different levels of Y as something moves
in the X direction it's going to be
rotated right there's going to be an it
you could almost view it as there's a
net torque there's a net torque on an
object that sits in the water here and
the ultimate would be let me draw
another vector field the ultimate would
be if I had this situation let me draw
another vector field if I had this
situation where maybe down here it's
like this then maybe it's like this and
then maybe it gets really small and then
maybe it switches directions
here and then the vector field goes like
this so you can imagine so up here
that's going to the left with a fairly
large magnitude so if you put a twig
here you would definitely hopefully see
that the twig not only will it not be
shifted to the right this side is going
to be moved to the left this is going to
be the right it's going to be rotated
and you'll see that there's a net torque
on the twig so what's the intuition
there all of a sudden we care about how
much is the magnitude of a vector
changing not in its direction of motion
like in the divergence example but we
care how much is the magnitude of a
vector changing as we go perpendicular
to its direction of motion so when we
learned about dot and cross product what
did we learn we learned that the dot
product of two vectors tells you how
much two vectors move together and the
cross product tell you how much the
perpendicular it's it's kind of the
multiplication of the the perpendicular
components of a vector so this might
give you a little intuition of what is
the curl because the curl essentially
meant measures what is the the
rotational effect or I guess you could
say what is the curl of a vector field
at a given point and you can you can
visualize that you put a twig there what
would happen to the twig if the twig
rotates and there's some curl if it if
the magnitude of the rotation is larger
than the curl is larger if it rotates in
the other direction you'll have the
negative direction of curl and so just
like when we did with torque we now care
about the direction because we care
whether it's going counterclockwise or
clockwise so we're going to end up with
a vector quantity right so and all of
this should hopefully start fitting
together at this point we've been
dealing with this Dell vector or this
you know we could call this abuse of
notation but it kind of is intuitive
although it really doesn't have any
meaning when I just write it like this
you can kind of write it as it's a
vector operator and then it has a little
bit more meaning
but this Dell operator we use it a bunch
of times you know it's the partial
derivative of something the I direction
plus the partial derivative something
with respect to Y in the J direction
plus the partial derivative well this is
if we do it in three dimensions
with respect to Z in the K direction
when we applied it to just a scalar
vector field you know like a three
dimensional function we just multiply
this times that scalar function we got
the gradient when we took the dot
product when we took the dot product of
this with a vector field we got we got
the divergence of the vector field and
this should be a little bit intuitive to
you at this point because when we you
might want to review our original videos
where we compared the gradient sorry
when we compare the dot product to the
cross product because the dot product
was how much do two vectors move
together so when you're taking this this
this del operator and dotting it with a
vector field you're saying how much is
the vector field changing right all a
derivative is a partial derivative or
normal derivative it's just a rate of
change partial derivative with respect
to X is rate of change in the X
direction so all you're saying is when
you're taking a dot product how much is
my rate of change increasing in my
direction of movement how much of my
rate of change in the Y Direction
increasing in the Y direction and so it
makes sense that it helps us with
divergence because remember if we had it
you know if this is a vector and then as
we increase just in the X direction the
vectors increase we took a little point
and we said oh at any given at this
point we're going to have more leaving
than entering so we have a positive
divergence but that makes sense also
because as we go in the X direction the
magnitudes of the factors increase
anyway I don't want to confuse you too
much so now the intuition because now we
don't care about the rate of change
along with the direction of the vector
we care about the rate of change of the
magnitudes of the vectors perpendicular
to the direction of the vector so the
curl you might guess is equal to the
cross product is equal to the cross
product of our del operator and the
vector field and if you if that was
where your intuition led you and that is
what your guess is you would be correct
that is the curl of the vector field and
it is a measure of
what is how much is that field rotating
or maybe if you imagine an object in the
field how much is the field causing
something to rotate because it's
exerting a net torque because at
different points in the object they you
haven't magnitude of a field in the same
direction anyway don't want to confuse
you too much hopefully that example I
just showed you will make a little bit
of a sense anyway I've realized I've
already pushed nine minutes in the next
video I'll actually compute curl and
maybe we'll try to draw a couple more to
hit the intuition home see you in the
next video